To build more muscle
Most people think it’s just about protein and training.
But in fact, gut bacteria and fiber are key to how efficiently your muscles recover.
Studies show that when we eat fiber, gut bacteria break it down
into short-chain fatty acids — butyrate, propionate, and acetate.
These molecules don’t just support digestion; they lower inflammation,
boost mitochondrial energy production,
and even promote muscle protein synthesis and recovery.
Interestingly, sports science research discovered that a bacteria called Veillonella
can convert the lactic acid produced during exercise into propionate,
which helps reduce fatigue and directly improves endurance.
So whether it’s fiber being converted into SCFAs
or Veillonella turning lactic acid into propionate,
scientific evidence now shows that gut bacteria don’t just influence digestion—
they directly impact muscle recovery and endurance.
So naturally, many people wonder—
if gut health matters that much,
can taking probiotics actually help recovery or muscle growth?
That’s why we’ve invited a microbiome and immunology expert,
Dr. Wen-Hsin Lin,
to help us unpack what the latest research really shows.
Dr. Lin, many people are curious—
can probiotics really help with muscle repair or growth?
Or is it something that only affects the gut?
We conducted a systematic review of 35 clinical trials
involving more than 1,300 participants.
We found that probiotics slightly reduce body weight and body fat,
significantly reduce post-exercise CK levels
(a marker of muscle damage),
and increase VO₂ max by an average of 1.55 mL/kg/min.
While the increase in muscle mass overall wasn’t statistically significant,
it was noticeable in men and regular exercisers.
So the clinical evidence consistently points toward
better recovery and endurance,
though not everyone will necessarily build more muscle.
It depends on training habits, strain type, and diet.
So if probiotics really help recovery,
does that mean people should also increase fiber intake
to help these bacteria work better?
Absolutely.
Without enough fiber, probiotics don’t have the “fuel”
they need to produce short-chain fatty acids effectively.
That’s why we often call fiber “the fertilizer” for gut bacteria.
Different types of fiber can also make a difference—
for instance, resistant starches or inulin fibers may perform differently.
So which type should we prioritize?
Are some fibers more effective than others?
Yes, different fibers act as food for different bacterial species.
Inulin, found in chicory root, promotes the growth of bifidobacteria,
while resistant starch feeds species that generate more butyrate.
A good balance of fibers is crucial
if you want your microbiome to support muscle recovery.
In my clinic, I often see patients who try to gain muscle
or control blood sugar
but have poor gut health.
Even if they eat plenty of protein and train hard,
they remain thin and under-muscled.
To truly turn “faster recovery” into “visible muscle gain,”
you need not only protein and resistance training
but also sufficient fiber intake.
For patients with diabetes, insulin resistance
slows down recovery.
By improving gut flora and reducing inflammation,
muscle recovery becomes more efficient.
In many weight loss cases,
people focus only on high protein intake
and ignore fiber,
which leads to poor gut flora and slower recovery.
At Sunrise Clinic,
we don’t just prescribe probiotics.
We start with gut function assessments—
checking for microbial imbalances,
nutrient absorption issues, and inflammation markers.
Then we personalize the approach:
fiber-rich diet, quality protein, resistance training,
and only then add probiotics when needed.
That way, the effect is steady and sustainable.
Recently, several studies have shown fascinating results.
For example, in the TWK10 study,
healthy men took the probiotic for six weeks.
Their endurance increased by 1.24 times,
grip strength improved on both hands,
lactate and ammonia levels dropped,
and muscle mass increased.
Then there’s the CP2305 study with Japanese long-distance runners.
After 12 weeks, their fatigue levels dropped,
anxiety and depression eased,
and they maintained hemoglobin while boosting growth hormone.
Finally, in a study of elite cyclists taking a multi-strain probiotic,
VO₂max didn’t increase significantly,
but GI discomfort improved noticeably,
and they felt less fatigued during training.
Each study had its own highlight:
TWK10 focused on endurance and strength,
CP2305 on stress recovery,
and the multi-strain product on gut health.
Of course, larger studies are still needed to confirm the real-world impact.
So Dr. Lin, in clinical terms,
how should people choose which probiotic to take?
That’s a great question.
It really depends on your goal and situation.
If your focus is on endurance, TWK10 might be more suitable.
If you’re under high stress or intense training,
then CP2305 might be the better choice.
For athletes prone to GI discomfort,
a diverse multi-strain product can help.
Most of these studies ran for at least 6 to 12 weeks,
so patience matters.
And don’t forget—fiber intake is essential.
It’s the “feed” that helps these bacteria produce SCFAs,
which amplify the benefits.
Also, combine probiotics with proper protein intake
and resistance training.
That’s how the recovery advantage translates
into measurable muscle gain.
So why do some people say they feel no difference
even after taking probiotics for a while?
There are a few common reasons.
First, they might be taking the wrong strain—
for example, using a “stress-relief” strain
when what they really want is muscle recovery.
Second, they don’t eat enough fiber,
so their SCFA levels never rise.
Third, the duration or dosage might be too low—
most studies used at least 6 weeks.
Other factors like antibiotic use, poor sleep,
or irregular schedules
can also disrupt the gut ecosystem
and reduce the probiotic’s effect.
And finally, misplaced expectations—
“better recovery or endurance”
doesn’t necessarily mean “instant muscle growth.”
That’s why I always remind patients to manage their mindset,
not just their supplements.
I totally agree.
I actually had a patient in my weight management clinic
who struggled to build muscle
despite consistent workouts and a high-protein diet.
She often felt bloated and tired,
so we ran a gut test.
It showed an imbalance in her gut microbiota
and mild inflammation.
We adjusted her diet—added more prebiotics and fiber,
plus a targeted probiotic strain.
Within a few weeks, her digestion improved,
her soreness decreased,
and she lost weight with minimal muscle loss.
It really shows how gut health, diet, and exercise
must work together.
When we corrected her gut flora, her recovery time shortened,
and training became much more effective.
It’s a great example of how restoring balance in the gut
can unlock muscle growth.
Dr. Lin, since you’ve reviewed so many studies,
how do probiotics actually influence metabolism?
Well, some probiotic strains can regulate inflammation
and improve insulin sensitivity.
That’s crucial for both diabetics and people trying to gain lean muscle.
Others affect mitochondrial function,
which helps cells generate more energy for recovery.
In short, probiotics can influence how efficiently
our muscles repair after training.
But we have to remember—they’re not a shortcut to muscle growth.
They work best as part of an integrated approach:
training, diet, rest, and gut balance.
That’s so true.
I’ve noticed that patients who balance all those elements
not only recover faster but also feel more energetic overall.
And as a metabolism specialist,
I see this connection all the time.
For instance, diabetics often have slower muscle recovery
because of insulin resistance.
When we manage inflammation and gut flora together,
their recovery improves noticeably.
Some even find that their blood sugar levels stabilize more easily.
So for them, improving gut health isn’t just about digestion—
it’s part of their metabolic therapy.
I completely agree.
That’s also why I emphasize prebiotics.
Without enough prebiotic fibers,
those probiotics can’t perform optimally.
Prebiotics like inulin, resistant starch,
and galactooligosaccharides
act as the “fuel” that gut bacteria use
to produce short-chain fatty acids.
These SCFAs, especially butyrate and propionate,
are the real mediators behind muscle recovery.
They enhance mitochondrial biogenesis,
reduce inflammation,
and may even influence gene expression related to muscle synthesis.
So the gut–muscle axis isn’t just a theory—
it’s a metabolic communication network.
That’s a fascinating way to put it.
Almost like your muscles “listen” to your gut.
Exactly. When the gut is inflamed or unbalanced,
that “signal” gets distorted.
So the muscle doesn’t receive the same biochemical cues
to regenerate properly.
That’s why both gut and muscle health
should be addressed together.
I think that perspective really helps patients understand
why gut tests are important.
Yes, exactly. Gut assessments reveal hidden issues
like dysbiosis or malabsorption.
They also help identify inflammation markers
that affect recovery and performance.
When patients see that data, they finally realize
why “just protein” isn’t enough.
Once they adjust their diet and balance their gut,
their training results skyrocket.
That’s what I love about this field—
it connects microbiology with real clinical outcomes.
And it gives patients a sense of control
over something they can actually improve daily.
Speaking of practical value, let’s talk about probiotics on the market.
There are so many kinds — live strains, heat-killed, encapsulated, refrigerated.
How should people choose which type is really effective?
That’s an important question. Each type serves a different purpose.
Live probiotics contain active bacteria that colonize the gut temporarily.
They’re sensitive to heat and stomach acid, so the way they’re stored and consumed matters.
Heat-killed or “postbiotics” still retain beneficial cell wall components
that modulate the immune system and improve barrier integrity.
Encapsulated strains are designed to survive stomach acid
and reach the intestines intact.
And refrigerated types are simply more sensitive live cultures
that need cooler temperatures to stay active.
In short, “more expensive” doesn’t always mean “more effective.”
It depends on the strain stability, target function, and your own gut condition.
Then how can consumers make smarter choices
without doing a full gut microbiome test?
Good question. You can start by checking a few things on the label.
First, make sure the product lists a specific strain ID—
not just “Lactobacillus,” but for example “Lactiplantibacillus plantarum TWK10.”
Second, look for published clinical evidence from universities or hospitals,
not just “company data.”
Third, check the CFU count—colony-forming units—
which tells you the viable dose per serving.
Usually, you want at least one billion CFU per dose,
depending on the strain and your goal.
Fourth, multi-strain formulas are often better
because they can support multiple functions at once.
For example, one strain for gut regularity,
another for immune modulation, and one for metabolism.
That’s why I summarize it as the four essentials
for probiotics to actually work.
First, academic backing;
second, adequate dosage;
third, diversity in strain functions;
and fourth, support immune modulation.
Only when all four are met can probiotics truly support gut and muscle health.
That’s very clear and practical advice.
I think a lot of people will realize it’s not about chasing “high CFU” numbers
or the most expensive brand,
but about choosing the right strain for their own body and goal.
Exactly. Think of probiotics like team members—
each has a specialty.
You don’t send a “stress management” strain
to do an “endurance enhancement” job.
The right combination makes the whole system perform better.
And if you feed them well—with fiber and prebiotics—
that’s when the real synergy happens.
So whether you’re training, recovering,
or just trying to stay healthy,
take care of your gut first—
because it’s the foundation for everything else.
That’s such a powerful takeaway.
“Strong muscles start with a strong gut.”
Absolutely.
And it’s something we can all start improving today.
Eat more diverse fibers,
get consistent sleep, and manage stress—
these simple habits help your microbiome
do its best work for your body.
Well said. Thank you, Dr. Lin,
for sharing so many insights today.
I think this conversation will help many people
see gut health in a whole new way.
Thank you, Dr. Chen.
It was a pleasure discussing this with you.
And hopefully, more people will understand
how the gut and muscles are deeply connected.
Exactly. When you take care of your gut,
you’re not just improving digestion—
you’re optimizing performance, recovery,
and long-term metabolic health.
That’s the real science behind
“you are what you eat.”
Thank you all for watching.
I’m Dr. Wei-Lung Chen from Sunrise Clinic.
Stay healthy, train smart,
and don’t forget to feed your gut.
We’ll see you in the next video.